and that hero you just heard about uh
nick bostic joins me exclusively right
now nick great to see you so i as as i
understand this story you come to the
house right it's on fire you don't know
if people are inside or outside you run
in and you find out that what the the
family was sleeping when this fire was
burning
yeah i'm i'm assuming the family was
asleep um
it took a few moments before uh people
came flying out of the top stairs door
um
uh but yeah um i was i went in through
the back door was hollering um if
anybody was in there and uh i've made it
like three steps up the staircase and
then outpoured uh for the the
older
the
for the children other than the six year
old you know um so i turned around in
front of them and let them out the back
door
and um i asked them who else was left in
there if anybody and they said that the
two-year-old or no the six-year-old was
in there
so
i went back in there and nick search for
him yeah tell me about that because
this is when the the smoke is all over
inside the house the flames are starting
to shoot up tell me about going back in
for the six-year-old
it was dark
um
it was dark um it was real silent it was
like a silent dead killer um for sure i
would call it um when i went back inside
and upstairs and got finished looking
upstairs started to go uh to the stairs
and go back down to look at the first
floor when i got there
smoke was already filled up up halfway
up the staircase and it wasn't just like
light smoke medium smoke heavy smoke it
was like real heavy like real heavy
smoke
um i made my way down there um and i
heard i heard the infant or the
six-year-old i heard her crying and
as you'll probably heard it i doubled
over my shirt and i went down there with
my eyes closed and my hand reached out
and i used my ears to guide me to her
voice
and
i picked her up and i ran to the stairs
well i ran to the back door but i
couldn't find it i felt like i was
getting more lost the further i'd go try
and find it it should have just been
straight from the a straight shot to the
staircase when you it went in from the
back door but it didn't
it didn't
wasn't like that for some reason i guess
that night you know so i went back
upstairs where i seen light yeah and
i tripped at the last staircase and fell
um got back up made it to the window in
the that bedroom of the side of the
house i
went to ripping blinds off the string
got caught around um kelani's leg or
ankle and i had to stop all what i was
doing and make sure that was completely
unwrapped from around her otherwise that
was going to put my
choice in
saving her life and mine
hers in jeopardy you know so hey
i gotta go in about 15
15 seconds tell me about what injuries
did you have
um
i got a real deep laceration on my
forearm
blisters
a numerous amount of blisters i'm
recovering great though no broken bones
i'm ready to go i'm vomit ready buddy
listen nick i gotta i gotta run
uh thank you for your bravery
masculinity we'll be right back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else